This video is brought to you by Nebula. Watch
our bonus videos with F-16 test pilot David
Kern by signing up to Nebula for only 2.50
a month.
A fully loaded F-16 is a force to be reckoned
with. An air superiority machine that countries
the world over use to patrol their skies.
A low cost, lightweight, single engine fighter,
specifically designed to out maneuver its
opponents while carrying state of the art
missiles that would, hopefully, mean it would
never have to.
The F-16 was born out of the Vietnam war.
Large, heavy, complex US fighters like the
F-4 Phantom were the norm, but the F-4 found
itself in pearl frequently, at a significant
disadvantage when taking on the smaller maneuverable
soviet-made MiGs of the Vietnamese Air Force,
like the Mig 21.
The Mig 21 was a small, single engined, lightweight
aircraft with thin delta wings. The F-4 was
fast, flying up to Mach 2.2, traveled further,
and carried more missiles, with a powerful
radar.
But, its lack of maneuverability at low speed,
poor pilot visibility and easy identification
due to jet engines that billowed black smoke
trails, made it vulnerable to sneak attacks
from the soviet interceptor.
MiG 21s frequently flew close to the ground,
under radar, and ambushed incoming F-4s. Making
a single attacking run with their Atoll infrared
guided missiles, and then, using their low
speed maneuverability to out turn and escape.
From August 1967 to February 1968, US losses
in Vietnam were staggering.
Losing 18 aircraft while downing just 5. [REF]
[1]
For a nation accustomed to absolute air superiority,
something was off.
The MIG 21s introduction in 1966 forced the
US to adapt. Its large, heavy fighter bombers,
while useful, were at a disadvantage against
these smaller, cheaper planes, and something
needed to be done.
The Red Baron study, commissioned by the US
Military, began to identify and address the
tactical and technical issues causing the
heavy losses that both the US Navy and Air
Force were experiencing in the Vietnam war.
And their findings led to the development
of one of the world’s most ubiquitous fighter
planes. A plane designed with a new physics
based doctrine at its core.
Entering service in 1978 and standing the
test of time, it is now confirmed that the
aircraft will be entering the battle for Ukraine’s
freedom, taking on the modern day counterparts
of the MiG.
This is the Insane Engineering of the F-16.
The F-16 was built from the ground up with
this classified 1966 paper as its guiding
light. A paper full of mathematical models,
graphs, and equations, designed to answer
one question.
How to win a close quarters dog fight. Created
with the help of military supercomputers,
it defined a new concept. Energy Maneuverability.
Created by Colonel John Boyd, an air force
veteran of the Vietnam war, and one of the
members of the so called fighter mafia, with
the help of a civilian mathematician Thomas
Christie. [REF][2]
These graphs were the basis for defining a
plane's maneuverability through its full range
of speeds. Mach number on the x-axis. Turn
rate on the y.
A theory underlined by the management of both
kinetic and potential energy, speed and altitude.
In order to change direction a fighter aircraft
must trade energy from these reservoirs, and
doing it as efficiently as possible is the
key to out maneuvering an enemy. .
This is the energy-maneuverability diagram
for the F-16. It’s a complicated graph to
read without some basic understanding. This
line is defined by the maximum lift of the
aircraft.
This is important because it determines the
maximum turn rate at a particular speed in
this region. We need lift to turn.
To begin a turn an aircraft will roll in the
direction of the turn. This splits the lift
the plane is generating into two components:
a horizontal component that causes the plane
to turn and a vertical component that keeps
the plane in the sky.
A steeper bank angle will increase the horizontal
component and increase our rate of turn, while
stealing lift from the vertical component.
This vertical component needs to equal the
weight of the aircraft, or the plane will
lose altitude. To compensate for that the
pilot will need to increase lift by increasing
the angle of attack. This is where the maximum
lift issue arises. More lift means more available
force to turn.
To determine the max turn rate for an F-16
at mach 0.4 we simply draw a line straight
up and across to our turn rate. 13 degrees
per second. Now, this is where things get
interesting. This is the graph for an F-4E.
At the same speed the F-4 can make a maximum
turn of just 5 degrees per second.
To determine a sustained turn we look to this
line labeled with a 0. Meaning no loss of
altitude is required to make the turn. We
can see the F-16s best sustained turn is 14.2
degrees per second at 0.85 Mach at 7 g. The
F-4s best sustained turn is 10 degrees per
second at 0.85 Mach at 5 g.
This is what that looks like in practice.
It takes the F-16 25 seconds to complete a
full 360 degree turn. While it takes the F-4
36 seconds. 11 seconds in the difference.
The F-16 was a radical new way of thinking
about fighter aircraft and that
design philosophy can be seen with how the
engine inlet has been designed to deal with
supersonic flow. To learn more about the F-16,
we spoke with F-16 test pilot David Wren.
so the F 16 inlet is one of those things that
tells you about the design philosophy of the
aircraft because up until that point, the
thought process was we wanted to go faster,
we wanted to go higher, and nobody stopped
to ask why, because it turns out that not
a lot of fights, not a lot of air combat was
happening in that mach two plus range. In
fact, very little of it was happening and
it didn't have a huge amount of tactical application.
And so as John Boyd and the rest of the team
was looking at this lightweight fighter design,
which became the F 16, they said, well, where
do we think that the dog fights of the future
are really going to happen? And they said,
well, it's probably going to be somewhere
in that 0.8 mach to 1.2 mock regime.
That's really where we need to be in terms
of optimizing the performance of the jet.
And we see that here in terms of the specific
excess power chart where it's got this advantage
right here in that range of 0.8 M to 1.2 mach.
That's where the fat part of the chart sits.
That's where your fat on energy, that's where
you have that advantage. And so the F 16 propulsion
system is not optimized to go over mach two,
although it can, and I've flown the F 16 at
Mach two, you run out of gas pretty quick,
but you can go that fast. But in that what
we call transonic regime of 0.8 to 1.2 mach,
you've got a different design problem than
some of the previous jets. And you can see
that in terms of the inlets. The inlets on
the F four have this extension that goes sort
of along the cheeks of the aircraft forward,
and then the actual inlet is inlets are set
back, and what that's designed to do is attach
a shockwave to the front of that inlet lip
and then it goes backwards and expands along
the body.
And that shockwave is basically going to cover
up the inlet that has some thermodynamic effects
in terms of pressure recovery for the fan
face because you don't want supersonic air
getting all the way in to your turbine. If
you have supersonic airflow hitting the front
face of that jet engine, the jet engine's
going to disintegrate. It's designed to ingest
subsonic airflow. And so you have to attach
that shock wave at the front of the inlet.
That's part of what slows down the airflow
to eventually a normal shock inside the inlet.
It expands a little bit and then it gets to
the front face of the compressor or the fan
face of the compressor. Well, the F 16, and
you can see it right here, has what we call
a peto inlet. It's basically a flat face air
scoop. It is not that sort of overhang with
a lip and then an inlet that's further back
like you see on the F four or the F 15 or
the F 14, the big 29, the s U 27, all of those
have more of that inlet that's set up to put
an oblique shockwave across the front of the
inlet.
Those are designed to go faster. The F 16
has a little bit of that. If you look at it
on a side view, you can see how it's got a
little bit of an overhang on the lip and the
nose helps to attach a shockwave, but it's
not as efficient to go above Mach 1.2. And
that's okay. Actually it can go that fast,
it can go faster, but the engine is working
a little bit harder as it gets into this 1.4,
1.5 mock range compared to something like
an F four or an F 15. That's where they start
to really stretch their legs and run.
These design optimizations for optimizing
maneuverability at these speeds can be seen
elsewhere too.
It’s air intake placement underneath the
aircraft, a stark difference to the side mounted
twin intakes of the F-4. And the thin elongated
wing that blends smoothly into the fuselage
with these wing extensions forward of the
main wing. These are called leading edge strakes
.
This air intake ensured the F-16s engine was
not starved of air during high angle of attack
maneuvers. With the forebody of the aircraft
helping to funnel and divert air directly
into the air intake.
However, this does come with some problems
that needed to be engineered around.
On take off and landing this air intake is
just 100 centimeters of the ground, this combined
with the extremely thin wings make placement
of the landing gear difficult.
The forward landing gear could not be mounted
ahead of the air intake, as they would kick
up debris into it, and they couldn’t fit
into the wings, as the thin aerodynamically
optimized wing didn’t have enough space.
The F-16s landing gears are stored just behind
the air intake, and in order to provide enough
stability and bracing on landing, they need
a unique folding mechanism to swing them outward
to create as large a wheelbase as possible.
The front landing gear, which is steerable
during taxi, also rotates 90 degrees to lie
flat just under the engine inlet.
Above the inlet is a boundary layer diverter
channel. This ensures the engine gets consistent
laminar flow.
As air travels along the length of the aircraft
it forms a layer of slow moving turbulent
air called a boundary layer. If this air is
allowed to enter the engine it not only lowers
performance, it can also damage the engine.
As the turbine rotates it will pass through
the slow boundary air on one side and then
fast free stream air on the other. This means
the force on the turbine blade changes for
each and every rotation, causing cyclical
bending. A recipe for fatigue failure.
This boundary layer diverter separates this
layer and diverts it underneath the wings.
All of this ensures the engine can operate
at as high a thrust as possible, even when
the F-16 is performing extreme maneuvers,
which is exactly when it is needed most as
the plane bleeds energy to produce lift.
It’s essential that a plane like this can
continue to generate effective lift during
these maneuvers,
but typical wings lose lift as angle of attack
increases beyond a certain angle, as flow
separates from the wing. This is called a
stall.
These leading edge strakes help to mitigate
that.
They act similarly to the canards of the SU-34,
one of the planes the F-16 will likely be
going up against in Ukraine, with 19 of them
reportedly being taken down thus far in the
war.
Canards and leading edge strakes help produce
lift during high angle of attack maneuvers.
Canards placed close to the wing, like the
Saab 37 Viggen, create a vortex that passes
over the wing, ensuring the wing continues
to get high energy airflow during high angle
of attack maneuvers which allows it to continue
generating lift
During the development of the F-16, General
Dynamics did consider a canard configuration,
testing different configurations and geometries
including versions with no strakes or canards
with subscale models in wind tunnel, testing
through its optimum maneuvering speeds between
0.4 and 0.8 mach.
The goal was to maximize lift and minimize
drag at high angles of attack, producing graphs
like this, and these were used to compare
designs.
As they were narrowing down on the design
they consulted NASA, and they found one area
to improve on.
The sharpness of the leading edge.
General Dynamics had rounded the leading edge
of the wing to weaken these high angle of
attack vortices[REF][3] , but NASA advised
them to sharpen the leading edge in order
to strengthen them.
The F-16 underwent a great deal of iterative
design in the wind tunnel phase before eventually
landing on the design we are familiar with
today. With the long blended leading edge
strake that makes the F-16 immediately recognisable,
and this comes with an added benefit.
It provides enough space for the barrel of
F-16s powerful 20 mm rotary cannon. [REF][4]
You can see the barrel of M61 Vulcan hiding
here, a minor clue to the weapon hidden within
the fuselage of the tiny plane.
One of the early conclusions of the Red Baron
report was that lackluster armament of the
F-4 made it difficult for it to compete in
close quarter battles. It lacked an internal
cannon, which left the F-4 without offensive
options in close quarter battles, where missiles
could not be safely used. The F-4 was eventually
retrofitted with the M61 slung underneath
the plane.
But, the F-16, looking to fix the problems
of the past, came with General Dynamics M61
Vulcan rotary gatling cannon as standard,
and was packaged neatly inside the plane,
creating minimal aerodynamic drag.
The M61 is the smaller cousin of the A-10s
GAU 8/A, and while its rounds are tiny in
comparison. The noise it emits still packs
a punch. A massive cannon for a tiny aircraft.
[REF] [5]
The 6 barrelled cannon fires from the top
position. Spinning 16 times a second, the
gatling cannon spews 100 20 mm rounds per
second. [REF] [6] With an ammunition drum
capable of holding just 511 rounds, the full
ammunition drum can be unloaded in just over
5 seconds.
The drum fits neatly behind the pilot here,
and the vibration of gun firing on the pilot's
left side is jarring for many new pilots.
It is such a small fighter, and I think I've
said this before, when you get into an F 16,
you sit down and you strap into that. It's
not like you're sitting in the jet. It's like
you're wearing the jet and the gun is right
here. As I sit there in the cockpit, the gun
barrels, the muzzles are right back here.
It's just out of reach. It's so close though.
And so when you shoot the gun and you're shooting
a hundred rounds a second of 20 millimeter,
it is unbelievably violent in the jet, but
you're thinking about the target that you
have to go and shoot.
And so one of my experiences flying the F
16 was I was teaching as an instructor pilot
at Luke Air Force Base in Phoenix, Arizona.
And so I had the privilege of taking in Air
Force pilots, they're wearing wings, they've
graduated Air Force pilot training, but they're
not fighter pilots yet. And putting them into
an F 16 and then we would make sure that everybody
shot the gun in training. In fact, they had
to qualify with the gun as a weapon. And so
the first time experience for anybody shooting
the gun in an F 16 is a little bit of an emotional
experience. People would say funny things,
they would cuss. It was all on the tapes,
the HUD tapes, the heads up display recordings,
and we come back in the debrief and we kind
of laugh at the students because they knew
that they were going to go shoot the gun and
it was always shooting at a target on the
ground is when they would do this for the
first time, raf.
And so it's a little bit intense. You're diving
at the ground, you're doing 4 50, 500 knots
pointed at the ground. Obviously there's a
survival instinct that kicks in there. You're
trying to put the pepper on the target, you
pull the trigger for the first time and the
whole jet shakes violently. It's like somebody
started up a chainsaw just in your left ear
and the whole jet is shaking and your hand's
on the throttle there. And I can always remember
every time I would shoot the gun, there's
this hard foam insulation that's just behind
the closeout panel, but the vibrations would
cause some of those little bits of foam to
fleck off, to flake off. And they would come
around the closeout panel and every time I
would go shoot the gun for practice a straight
I'd come back, and as I'm getting out of the
airplane, I'd see these little yellow flex
of foam all over my green flight suit on my
left arm.
The vibrations were so intense, you get used
to it after the first time you shoot it, it's
a little bit of an emotional event. And then
after that you're focused on, I need to put
those rounds on target. So the F 16 is incredibly
well integrated as far as a weapon system
with that gun. And I'll tell you that both
for air to ground and also for air-to-air,
the gun sites on the F 16 are incredibly precise.
And even with dynamics on the aircraft, even
under maneuvers in terms of air-to-air shoots
where we're shooting at a banner, there's
not been a lot of actual air-to-air dog fighting
with the gun in recent memory. But the F 16
is accurate when it shoots at air-to-air practice
targets to the point of it's almost not even
fair. It used to be kind of a scoring kind
of a skill thing.
And now you can just park the Pippa on the
target open up and it just t shreds anything
you pointed at in terms of an air-to-air target.
And then in terms of airto ground, you can
be extremely precise with it. It's not quite
a laser beam, but you can be extremely precise.
And there's even ways that you can couple
up other sensors on the aircraft and share
information, even in a at night blacked out
type of close air support roll, you can hit
what you want to hit on the ground.
All from a gun hidden away in this tiny fighter
plane.
If we follow this leading edge strake down
the wing we come to another device designed
to increase lift at high angles of attack.
The leading edge flap. It deflects downwards
during high angle of attack maneuvers to delay
stall, allowing air to remain attached to
the wing surface.
When performing a sustained turn at 0.9 Mach
at cruising altitude, it increases lift by
18% and decreases drag by 22%. You can see
them actuate here during the 5 g take off
I performed with the Thunderbirds back in
2019.
The seam between the leading edge flap and
the main wing is barely noticeable and fitting
a control system into this wing, which is
only around 4 centimeters thick where the
actuator system needed to fit, proved a challenge.
The amount of torque needed to actuate a control
surface like this at 0.9 Mach is not trivial.
To solve this problem power is transferred
from two hydraulic motors, which convert the
pressure in the hydraulic system into rotational
motion. The hydraulic drive motor itself is
tucked away behind the M61 Rotary cannon,
next to the hydraulic motor that drives the
cannon's rotation and ammo drive system. [REF]
[7] This power has to be transferred to the
wing, and this is done through a series of
torque shafts, angular gearbox, and down another
series of torque shafts with rotary actuators
in between.
[REF] [8]
This leading edge flap is not controlled by
the pilot however, it’s controlled automatically
by the flight computer, and the F-16 was ground
breaking in this regard. The F-16 was the
first fighter aircraft to have a fly by wire
system controlling every control surface.
The leading edge flaps, the flaperons, the
rudder, and the horizontal tail of F-16 are
not controlled directly by the pilot.
A fly by wire system using a network of sensors,
wires and computers as well as the pilots
own input to control the plane. The F-16 was
employing this new technological wizardry
to allow it to efficiently spend the energy
its single jet engine provided.
Traditional flight control systems, up to
this point, used a mechanical system
connected directly to the pilot's controls
to manipulate the flight surfaces. This is
footage of the F-4s control system. A heavy
and complicated network of cables, rods, linkages
and hydraulics. It even has a 2 kilogram bob
weights attached to the pilot's stick. A mechanism
designed to make it harder to pull the stick
as gs increase, an analog feedback system.
To provide the pilot with an analog feedback
on speed the F-4 also featured a diaphragm
that deflected with ram air taken from this
probe on the vertical fin. This introduced
a force that acted to push the stick backwards,
and indicated to the pilot to adjust a trim
setting. [FOOTAGE]
This system not only added a huge amount of
weight to the F-4, reducing it’s maneuverability,
it added workload to the pilot and was more
vulnerable to damage in dogfights with little
redundancy.
With a fly by wire system, none of this was
needed. The first batch of F-16s actually
had a stick that was immovable. It was just
force sensing. Later a small amount of movement
was added after pilots complained.
So the non movable stick kind of little known
fact, you know the original F 16, it wasn't
a Lockheed Martin product, it was general
dynamics and they had made the F one 11 previously,
tand the weapon system operator on the F one
11 had a small joystick that they could use
to steer the attack radar and that was a force
based movement. It wasn't really a joystick
that would move, it was just the apply force.
And so they took that same concept and then
they put it into the F 16 stick. So it was
sort of a general dynamics thing of we've
got a force transducer, a control in scepter
is what you'd call that.
So what it turns out though is that the human
body, does really well with knowing where
your limbs hands are moving, knowing the position
of your body is something that you naturally
do pretty well, and that is something called
proprioceptive feedback. Well, when I have
a force based inceptor, I don't get that proprioceptive
feedback anymore and it's really hard to judge.
It's something that I think if you challenge
yourself to go pick up a small weight at the
gym and ask yourself, how much does that weigh
without looking at it, it's actually kind
of hard to guess when you're down in those
few pounds range.
And the maximum force you can put on the F
16 sidestick is 25 pounds. So it's kind of
hard to tell the difference between 15 pounds
and 15.2 pounds. We don't do very well with
that. We do a lot better with knowing how
far we've pulled something. And so the original
F 16 controls didn't move, and what pilots
found was that they were having a difficult
time. The test pilots at Edwards were having
a difficult time judging exactly how hard
they would move the controls, and so they
would think they were going to get a certain
response from the jet and then they weren't,
and then they'd pull harder too hard and then
they'd get a different response. there is
a phenomenon called pilot induced oscillations
or pilot in the loop oscillations. Sometimes
it's just shortened to p i o and the F 16,
even to this day, particularly if you have
a lot of wing stores, can have a little bit
of a wing rock on landing. And if you look
at some videos of F sixteens landing, sometimes
you can find if they have wing tanks or they're
bringing back some bombs that they didn't
expend, you'll find an F 16 that'll sort of
do this little back and forth wing rock. And
that is still, to this day, it's an artifact
of having a sidestick that doesn't move very
much because it's one of those things that
in terms of the mind to the hand, eye hand
coordination, you start to make a movement.
By the time you see the effect, it's more
than you wanted. So you take it out, you put
in a correction. By the time the correction
takes effect, it's more than you wanted. You
see it, you come back. It's a feedback loop
in our minds. And now p i o is kind of a dirty
word in aircraft design and nobody wants any
PIOs. I'll tell you PIOs pilot induced oscillations
are like snakes and some snakes are very dangerous
and some snakes are not. And so the P I O
that's remaining in the F 16 in terms of its
wing rock on final at landing is not super
dangerous.
These pilot induced oscillations can also
be naturally stabilized through passive stability.
Where the plane naturally self corrects itself
without pilot input. However the F-16 was
the first aircraft in history to do away with
passive stability and make the plane intentionally
unstable in flight. This was done because
it lowers the energy needed to fly and maneuver.
We can understand why this is with a simple
analogy. Here we have two situations, a ball
placed on top of a hill and a ball placed
in a valley. If we push the ball on top of
the hill, even a tiny bit, it will begin to
accelerate down the hill and will not stop
until we put energy in to slow it down. This
is an unstable system.
The opposite is true for the ball in the valley.
Apply a force and the ball will roll uphill
and gravity will now provide a restoring force
to bring it back. It may oscillate back and
forth a few times before coming to a stop,
but it will eventually return to its original
position. This is a stable system.
We want to tailor our stability to find a
balance between these two scenarios. Where
we can cause a rapid change in direction with
a small energy input, while also managing
the amount of energy required to get back
to our original position. This is called relaxed
static stability.
The F-16 pitch stability is one of the areas
where this idea was applied. One of the key
factors that affects pitch stability is the
location of the center of gravity and center
of lift.
The center of gravity for the F-4 is located
about here. This is the point at which all
lift will act around, it’s like the fulcrum
on a see-saw. As a result of the wing design
the center of lift is slightly behind the
center of gravity. This would force the plane
to pitch downwards, but the horizontal stabilizer
provides counteracting downwards force.
This isn’t ideal, we are wasting energy
on downwards lift.
We need upward lift to fly. It also increases
the amount of energy the F-4 needs to input
to change its pitch.
When it pitches upwards the force on the horizontal
stabilizer decreases because of reduced air
flow, and as a result the weight of the plane,
acting through the center of gravity, forward
of the center of lift, wants to move the nose
down again.
But the pilot is trying to pitch the plane
up, and this natural stability is fighting
them. So more kinetic energy is wasted by
converting it to lift and drag with an increased
elevator deflection.
The F-16 is different. Its center of lift
is ahead of the center of gravity, in part
thanks to those leading edge strakes pushing
the center of lift forward. This means to
balance the plane the horizontal stabilizer
needs to create upwards lift. This is useful
lift and reduces the energy needed to keep
the plane airborne, and increases our maximum
lift pushing this line on our energy maneuverability
diagram up, increasing our turn rate.
However, it is an unstable system. When the
plane pitches up it increases the angle of
attack of the wing and increases the lift.
Because the center of lift is ahead of the
center of gravity this forces the noses up
even more.
In an air to air battle, energy isn’t just
a fuel burning problem. Energy is needed to
maneuver, and as we spend it our ability to
maneuver diminishes until we replenish it
by gaining speed or altitude again.
any fighter pilot will tell you speed is life.
And as a fighter pilot, energy management
is one of the most important things that you
can do. It's part of your situational awareness
in that combat arena. You don't want to get
slow and you don't want to put yourself in
a place where you are vulnerable and now I
can't turn, I can't move, I can't get my sensors
or my weapons engaged where I need to. And
that's not just an air-to-air thing that's
in every aspect of being a fighter pilot.
And that's even engaging in an air-to-ground
arena because oftentimes when you're engaging
air to ground, an interdiction mission, a
strike mission or close air support mission,
well you're supporting friendly troops on
the ground, but there's also people that really
don't like you in the vicinity and they have
weapons also. And so you have to maintain
that energy to be able to evade, to be able
to move out of the way if you're getting shot
at.
And so with the energy management on the F
16, it's interesting that this jet doesn't
really talk to you in terms of feedback to
the pilot. It doesn't really shake and rattle
and vibrate like a lot of other aircraft will
do. I've flown the F 16, I've also flown the
F 15, the F 18, the A 10, and those aircraft
will talk to you. Those other aircraft will
talk to you a lot more than the F 16. The
F 16 just feels smooth all the time, whether
you're 200 knots and really slow or you're
600 knots and really fast, it just sort of
does what you ask it to do. You think you
move the controls just a tiny bit and the
aircraft responds. So managing your energy
becomes a situational awareness challenge
for the fighter pilot. And so a lot of that's
helped now with the joint helmet mounted queuing
system or JE hemic is what it's called, where
right there in your right eye, you've got
your airspeed, you've got your altitude, you've
got your G, and so you can engage visually
in that fight. I can keep my eyes on the threat,
the target, keep situational awareness, and
I don't have to look back in at my heads up
display or down at the console to see how
fast I'm going and how high I'm going. You
get the feel for it. You get a feel for how
the aircraft is responding. But that's where
experience comes in and it's imperative experience
training comes in. It's imperative to maintain
that energy awareness in any kind of fight.
The unstable design of the F-16 helped fighter
pilots like David to manage energy more efficiently,
but to maintain control of an unstable fighter
a pilot would have to make constant tiny corrections.
A task deemed impossible before fly by wire
systems were invented.
The system consists of a network of accelerometers,
gyros and air speed sensors, all fed into
a central computer that manages the work.
This instability makes the plane extremely
nimble, ready to change direction with very
little energy input. We could see this in
practice on the first flight of the F-16 prototype,
the YF-16. A flight that was never supposed
to happen.
This was intended to be a short test along
the runway, but the early control logic of
the plane would not allow the engine nozzle
to open to cut thrust if the wheels had left
the ground. Meaning, even at idle, the plane
was generating too much thrust.
Then the plane rolled left, which caused the
pilot to counteract it with a roll right command,
but again the control logic of the early prototype
was not dialed in, with control input resulting
in higher roll than expected at such a low
speed. Resulting in an over correction, leading
to an oscillation.
With this being the first full fly by wire
plane, there many lessons to be learned along
the way
But the benefits it now provides are game
changing. It helps the pilot get the most
of out of the plane.
So for example, with an F 16, the airframe
is limited to nine Gs. And so I can go and
pull back on the controls on an F 16, and
if I am less than about 300 knots or so, actually
more like 400 knots, I'm not going to get
nine Gs. It's just that's how much lift the
aircraft can make. But once I get above about
400 to four 50 knots, now the wing on the
F 16 is capable of creating at least nine
Gs. In fact, it's capable of creating a lot
more than nine Gs. But what that fly by wire
system does is when I start pulling back all
the way to the stop, it goes to nine Gs and
it sits there. Even if the wing aerodynamic
effect of the whole airframe is that it could
generate 15 GSS or 20 gs, the fly by wire
system says, Hey, I know you're asking for
your best possible turn.
I'm just going to give you nine Gs because
we're not going to break the airplane. Or
again, in a slow speed fight where I'm having
to, it's less than 300 knots. I'm having to
crank the nose around to either bring my nose
onto the adversary or maybe I'm trying to
jin out of the way of an adversary's weapon
system, pull suddenly on the controls of an
aircraft and your angle of attack is going
to increase rapidly. Alright, well with a
lot of more conventional aircraft, you're
worried about things like stall. Well, the
F 16 doesn't really stall in the same kinds
of ways, but that flyby wire system says,
Hey, I know that if you get past about 26
degrees angle of attack, bad things are going
to start to happen. In terms of the controllability,
the F 16 stops behaving as predictably above
26 degrees angle of attack.
And so they fly by a wire system simply says,
that's where I'm going to stop you right there,
and I'm going to give you up to 26 degrees
or nine Gs and do with that whatever you need
to.
A plane capable of 9 g maneuvers is not much
use if the pilot cannot remain conscious during
them. The F-16 has some interesting adaptations
in the cockpit for this.
Traditionally the control stick was mounted
centrally, between the pilots legs. This made
it mechanically simpler, with the network
of mechanical linkages being central and symmetric
throughout the plane. It also allowed the
pilots to use both hands to wrestle the control
surfaces into position during high g maneuvers
as the air flowing by them tried to push them
back down.
For the F-16 this wasn’t a problem, and
the control stick was mounted conveniently
on the pilots right hand console. A comfortable
resting position that makes it far easier
for the pilot to control the plane while trying
to stay conscious at 9 gs.
The seat is also reclined by 30 degrees, this
makes the F-16 feel like an executive office
in the sky with unobstructed 360 degrees thanks
to the bubble canopy, but it also comes with
major advantages to increasing the pilots
g tolerance.
The most common g force a pilot experiences
is directly down. When flying in a straight
line even cells in your body have inertia
in that direction, and when suddenly pitching
the plane upwards, those cells want to continue
traveling in that direction.
This isn’t too much of a problem for cells
to stay fixed, but your blood cells are free
to travel through your body. And in a scenario
like this they race in the direction of that
travel, pooling in your lower extremities.
This starves the pilots brain of oxygen and
they can pass out as a result. This effect
could be minimized by placing the pilot flat
on their back, with the entire body aligned,
blood wouldn’t have to fight gravity to
get to the brain, but this position isn’t
practical.
The F-16 found a compromise with a 30 degree
recline, reducing the pressure on the heart
by the equivalent of about 1 g. The recline
also makes it easier to fit the pilot into
the diminutive forward fuselage of the f-16,
Another measure to increase the pilot's g-tolerance
is the g-suit. A pilots g-suit contains multiple
air bladders that are connected directly to
F-16. When the plane is instructed to perform
a high g-maneuver it immediately begins to
pump compressed air into these bladders. This
squeezes the pilots legs and to limit the
volume available for blood to pool into.
The F-16 is a 45 year old aircraft, and many
advances have occurred in aviation since its
maiden flight, stealth technology and interconnected
intelligence networks have been the main focus
for 5th generation aircraft like the F-35
that have been slowly replacing the F-16,
but one thing hasn’t changed since 1975.
Physics.
The F-16 pushes the boundaries of maneuverability
for a fighter aircraft and the pilots inside.
It’s a highly capable fighter aircraft that
the strongest air force in the world deemed
capable of continuing service until 2048.
The plane will be a major asset in the next
phase of the fight for Ukraines freedom, providing
essential air support to the troops on the
ground as they attempt to push forward through
entrenched Russian defenses.
Ukraine has been targeting long range anti
aircraft batteries with success, and captured
oil platforms off the coast of Crimea that
were housing Russian sensors. All to clear
the way for Ukrainian Su-24s to get close
enough to launch cruise missiles, targeting
high value Russian assets in Crimea, including
a kilo class submarine.
The F-16 can also carry these cruise missiles.
Every asset in the Ukrainian air force is
going to play a vital role in Ukraines fight
for freedom.
Having an actual fighter pilot add context
to this story was incredibly valuable, helping
us truly understand the power of those energy
maneuverability diagrams. We ended up talking
to David for nearly two hours and ended up
cutting an incredibly interesting story from
this video, about how he helped develop an
automatic obstacle avoidance system for the
F-16 that has saved lives. A fascinating system
that works in a way I didn’t expect, I had
assumed it simple uses radar to measure distance,
but that is not how it works. You can watch
that extra video on Nebula right now, along
with an uncut explanation of energy maneuverability
diagrams.
Access usually costs 5 dollars a month, but
you can get access right now with the huge
discounted price of just 2.50 a month, using
the link in the description.
Bonus videos are just one benefit to Nebula.
You will also get ad free versions of our
videos at a fraction of the price of YouTube
premium. With YouTube cracking down on ad
blockers this is the best way to support our
channel while not having to deal with ads
interrupting your viewing experience. Something
I find really valuable while watching long
form videos.
When I am taking flights to shoot interviews
I often download videos from Nebula, which
you can do by the way, and watch them on the
flight.
You will also get access to our original world
war 2 series, the Logistics of D-Day and the
Battle of Britain. As well as Real Life Lore’s
modern conflict series that deep dives into
conflicts like the War in Ukraine.
Along with originals from some of your other
favourite creators, Like Mustard, Practical
Engineering, Neo and Wendover Productions.
Nebula is simply the best place for our videos.
No ads, bonus videos, and exclusive high budget
originals and all for the price of 2.50 a
month.